وبسبب تكثيف الجيش الاسرائيلي وتعميقه
وتوسيعه لعملياته في خان يونس طبعا هذه
الحالات من الاصابات والاستشهاد بين صفوف
الفلسطينيين والتي تتركز حول مستشفى ناصر
في خان يونس الذي يعتبر المستشفى الوحيد
الذي يمكن ان يستقبل هؤلاء ينضم الان
الينا من جديد من هناك مؤمن شرافي مؤمن
كنا معك
قبل قليل فقط عندما قصف منزل في الجهه
الغربيه من المجمع مجمع ناصر
الطبي هل اتضحت تداعيات هذا
الاستهداف نعم ليلى بالحمد لله هذا المنزل
مخلى من من سكانه وهو غير ماهول
بالسكان سكان هذا المنزل نزحوا عنه بعد
القصف العنيف الذي تعرضت له مدينه خان
يونس والمنطقه المحيطه بمجمع ناصر الطبي
وانتقلوا الى مدينه رفح والغاره ادت الى
تدمير المنزل بشكل كامل وتطاير شضايا
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه الى حرم مستشفى ناصر
وايضا تساقطت على خيام النازحين في الساحه
الغربيه
من المستشفى ما ادى الى الحاق اضرار في
هذه الخيام اصلا النازحون طيله ساعات
الليل مع كثافه القصف الاسرائيلي تركوا
هذه الخيام واحتموا داخل ابنيه مستشفى
ناصر تحسبا لوقوع شضايا او قصف اسرائيلي
في محيطهم يوقع عدد من الضحايا ما تردنا
كل دقيقه مناشدات من قبل مواطنين لاجلاء
جرحى لهم عالقين داخل منازلهم لا تستطيع
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليهم ولا يستطيعون
هم كذلك الوصول الى تلك المنطقه لتواجد
دبابات واليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اخرون يناشدون باي وسيله نقل تقل جثامين
ابنائهم او بناتهم او اطفالهم الشهداء
للانتقال بهم الى مناطق اخرى في المنطقه
الوسطى هناك طريق سالك للمنطقه الوسطى
بدهر البلح ل يتم مواراته مؤثره بعد ان
حاصرت واحتلت قوات الاحتلال واليات
العسكريه المقبره الوحيده القريبه مستشفى
ناصر ويبدو ان جنود الاحتلال ينبشون
داخل قابر في هذه المقبره التي تبعد مئات
الامتار عن مجمع ناصر الطبي نسمع دوي
اشتباكات متفرقه في عدد من المناطق تحديدا
في منطقه بطن السمين هذه المنطقه على وجه
التحديد ما اود ان اذكره هو ان طائره
مروحيه اسرائيليه في تمام الساعه الثامنه
صباحا هبطت في هذه المنطقه ويبدو انها
الاجلاء مصابين من جنود جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وثم انتقلت الى منطقه الكتيبه
التي تتمركز فيها قوات واليات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه العمليه
البريه وهو موافقته عدسات الكمرا وافادات
شهود العيم بالاضافه الى اننا نسمع
اشتباكات تدور في المحور الجنوبي الشرقي
وايضا بموازاه المنطقه الغربيه الممتده من
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي كما ان قوات
الاحتلال تعتلي عدد من البنايات السكنيه
المرتفعه لقناص جيش الاحتلال الذي
يستهدفون المواطنين وايضا سيارات الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني التي تحاول الوصول الى
اكثر من منطقه لانتشال جثامين شهداء او
اجلاء عائلات محاصره تحديدا في منطقه
ابراج طيبه ومناطق اخرى متفرقه من مدينه
خان يونس وايضا في
محيط منطقه البلد بين الفينه والاخرى تقوم
دبابات جيش الاحتلال بقصف هذه المنطقه
بالقذائف الصاروخيه منطقه البلد شبه مدمره
بعد سلسله من الاحزمه الناريه التي نفذتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه نسفت مبان
سكنيه وتجاريه ومربعات باكملها عن بكره
ابيها وسوتها بالارض في محاوله للدخول
واحتلال هذه المنطقه التي تعد عصب مدينه
خان يونس وايضا تعد قلب المدينه لكنها ما
زالت متواجده الاشتباكات في محيط شارع
القسام والشوارع المؤديه الى هذه المنطقه
وايضا شارع خمسه الذي تستهدف فيه
الدبابات والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وهي الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه خنوس
تستهدف المنطقه الغربيه بكثافه ناريه حتى
هذه اللحظه لا لم يتبين طبيعه الاهداف
التي يسعى جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اليها
في الوصول الى المنطقه الغربيه هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه ساحليه ومنطقه الو
المواص هي منطقه ادعى جيش الاحتلال امنها
منطقه خضراء يمكن لسكان مدينه خانيونس
النزوح اليها
ل يكونوا بامان لكن لاحقتهم الصواريخ وبعض
الصواريخ والغارات التي استهدفت خيام
النازحين ومدارسهم ايضا تحاول قوات
الاحتيال الوصول الى تلك المنطقه نشاهد
الان وصول سياره
اسعاف يبدو انها تقل مصابين جدد افدنا قبل
قليل من عائله كانت تسكن في نازحه مدينه
غزه تسكن في منطقه البراق ان قوات
الاحتلال في ساعات الليل اقتحمت هذا
المنزل
لعائله النازحه واطلقت نيرانها على افراد
هذه العائله اصيبوا 38 فردا بجروح متفاوته
بينهم خمسه على الاقل جراحهم خطيره وصلوا
الى مجمع ناصر الطبي يناشدون الصليب
الاحمر بان هناك اثنين من افراد هذه
العائله لازالوا عالقين
داخل هذا المنزل يقولون ان قوات الاحتلال
احتجزت هذا العدد الكبير من افراد هذه هذه
العائله داخل غرفه واحده بعد اقتحام
المنزل واطلاق النار عليه وبداخله
واصابتهم بشظايا وب الرصاص يناشدون الصليب
الاحمر بضروره الوصول الى تلك المنطقه
لاجلاء رجل وابنه لازالوا داخل هذا المنزل
الذي اقتحمته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بحسب افاده شاهد عيان اتى الى هنا الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي وحدث الجزيره بهذه
الافاده افادات كثيره و هادات كثيره و حتى
عدم تمكن الطواقم الصحفيه والاسعاف وايضا
المواطنين من ووصول الى بعض المناطق يبدو
ان الساعات القادمه ستتكشف عن مزيد
من الجرائم التي ارتكبها جيش الاحتلال
سواء في المناطق التي توغل اليها او في
المنازل التي اقتحمها او البنايات السكنيه
المرتفعه التي اعتلت قناصه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الحديث اذا كنا نتحدث عن 45
شهيد
في خانيونس حتى هذه اللحظه في